und dann einfach ja wo bist denn du da
da drauf oh lol jetzt habe ich eine
Leiter kaputt
[Musik]
gemacht hallo und willkommen zurück
t3c genau hat sich ein bisschen komisch
angehört hallo willkommen zurück das war
eiglich mal eine tolle Betonung mal
etwas anders ich rushe dem Spark hier
gerade davon ja ja ich bin hier immer
noch in dem letzten Challenge oder so
dabei muss kurz
schreiben ja ja kein
Ding bisschen auf dann Skype guckt alles
voll tom hat mir geschrieben hanger
Games oh Gott ich komme jetzt gerade gar
nicht hin doch
da okay ach nee jetzt soll ich da rüber
springen so was meint er
denn ach so ja
Tom meint er hat sich stumm gestellt
ancheint nehmen wir gerade irgendwas
auf ach ihr schreibt unerufen ihr
schreibt dir gerade in unserem Chat n
spontan in Pool
gelangen
okay eingefallen K okay ja gut und welch
ist er
m ich bin schon relativ weit oben wollte
ich mal eben kurz anmerken ziemlich
ziemlich weit oben
oha der der hüpft mir noch davon hier
das geht nicht nein Alter ich war sowas
von weit oben das ist unglaublich wenn
du das gesehen hättest ich bin so 10
Milliarden Mal umher gehüpft ne 10
Milliarden Mal und ich habe die auch
geschafft
okay also irgendwo ganz ganz ganz ganz
ganz du musst erstmal nee da musst du
nicht du musst hier hin springen dahin
da wo ich hinschlage guck mal hier da ah
da ja und dann weiter auf die
Leiter
okay und jetzt und dann einfach ja wo
bist denn du da
da drauf oh lol jetzt habe ich eine
Leiter kaputt gemacht
die muss hängen ja Moment ich spring mal
kurz weiter vielleicht schaffe ich es ja
auch eben dann kannst du nämlich
durchgehen durch den Checkpoint dann
wäre das gar nicht weiter schlimm sonst
wenn ich runterfalle häng ich natürlich
sofort
an und ich bin
runtergefallenemine hey wo waren die
Leiter jetzt ich weiß gar nicht wo die
war die hängen hier ach da okay du
musstich jetzt hier drauf springen da wo
du stehst ja da war ich doch gerade hast
gesagt musst Weg so und dann halt hier
rüber und dann da wieder runter du musst
hoch runter springen wirklich alles auf
einmal ach so übrigens wo ich gerade
stehen geblieben war war hier
so ach schon wieder runtergefallen na
toll
fail
so das wird noch spannend nicht weil
slich schwer ist sondern weil es einfach
sonderlich viel ist
ja ihr seht ja gerade bei mir ja doch
ich weiß es mittlerweile
ungefähr es ist echt teilweise einfach
und dann wird's auf einmal wieder
ziemlich schwer ich weiß nicht wo ich
hin jumpen soll ich verstehe es nicht wo
bist denn du ach da unten ja auf diesen
ganz Kleinen da da hinten das geht ja
natürlich das ist mir Spinne
entgegenekommen
hat nein ich Fall komplett runter ach da
kommt man gar nicht her auch Gott und
ich versuch da unbedingt herzulaufen es
gibt do keine war eine Spinne die hat
mich im Flug abgefangen
lieb von ihr hast jetzt gehst hin gibst
so ein Keks hast du gut gemacht könn mir
Cookie cheaten
Cookie American
Cookie die sind gut ja die sind sehr
gut so zu viel Zombies ich entgifte mal
hier die area jetzt ich da noch runter
ich glaub es ja
nicht so viel Ungeziefer
drin man kann nicht dasuma SPK tötet
keine Tiere das zählt ja nicht das sind
auch Tiere das virtuelle Gewalt hast du
nicht FL geschaut nee ich guck dir nicht
aber ich habe schon mal live mit ihm
gesprochen echt ja Games ach so sch we
ichen her dann ja da hatte der ungefähr
so viel Abonnenten wie wir
jetzt da habe ich den als daar
angesehen das heißt wenn du dein wenn
ein vergangenheits ich dich jetzt sehen
würde würdest dich als du bist ein Star
also ach nee bin ja ich oh
scheiße ach das bin ja ich ach aber
irgendwie sagt keiner von sich selbst
dass er ein Star ist ganz einfach weil
es ihn normal ist ich finde das ist auch
besser so damit man einfach auf den
Boden bleibt nicht zu vi ab ist für mich
mittlerweile auch normal ich kann es
echt nicht verstehen wenn der teilweise
Leute zu mir sagen du bist der beste du
bist der allerbeste ich kann es einfach
nicht verstehen ja ich weiß was
mein hoffe mal du verstehst mich in dem
Belang ja klar klar ich weiß also für
mich ist es jetzt nichts Besonderes ein
Kanal mit knapp 40.000 Abonnenten zu
haben also für ich ja für mich
eigentlich auch nicht ich meine man hat
halt ein Kanal man hat seine Fans seine
Community das würde ich auch schon sagen
ich sag ich sag nicht mal Fans ich sag
Zuschauer ich brahaupte doch nicht dass
ich Fans
hab wenn du verstehst was ich in dem
Fall ja ja ich meine was du meinst
stimmt auch wieder man hat halt seine
Zuschauer
aber nein jetzt Fall ich auch noch
[Musik]
runter fast runtergefallen Leiter oh
Mann ich war vorhin fast fertig hiermit
als du noch im alten Level da warst ja
so kann man failen dann
manchmal so dann da hoch und dann da
hinten hoch geschafft ich bin aber auch
schon ziemlich weit gerade soll ich dich
mal ein bisschen lotzen kannst du machen
nee das geht noch das wird gleich schwer
ja da ist noch einfach rüber zu springen
der Rest ist auch
einfach
okay und da oben mste dann eigentlich
auch schon wieder der jetzt musst
eigentlich nur noch dich an dem Dingens
herhangeln wo ja da einfach weitergehen
wo du bist okay da sind Leitern
ja und jetzt noch
weiter und dann geht da jetzt eine
Leiter nach oben wenn du es siehst ja
okay gut und jetzt das gleiche quasi
noch mal ist ja easy nur dann ja danach
ja da auch noch
drüber danach jetzt nicht mehr drüber
weil da sind keine Leitern jetzt musst
du auf den nächsten drauf springen auf
den da ja auf den ganz
hohen jetzt auf den
daneben jetzt auf den den da Nein boah
das war der vorletzte ach
Spark schade ich dachte schon ich muss
gar nicht mehr los aber pass auf ich bin
ja ich bin nicht ganz runtergefallen wie
du
siehst jetzt überhole was kriege ich
dann keine Ahnung Kinderschokolade auf
der Gamescom Kinderschokolade du bist
doch e nicht dann da wenn ich nicht da
bin das ist ja das
witzige weiß du da musst du mir nichts
geben 10 Millionen EUR wenn wir uns auf
der Gamescom sehen stehst irgendwie auf
Kinderschokolade ja ich habe gerade
Kinderschokolade vor mir liegen deswegen
schon wieder eine gleichen Stelle
gefehlt und auch nicht ganz
runtergefallen s nur ein
Stück ich schaff es gerade gar nicht
neben der Aufnahme während der Aufnahme
sind Erwachsene die kinderchokolade
Essen eigentlich
[__]
[Gelächter]
okay kann ich einfach nur m zu
sagen ist so vom vom Wort von der
Wortgewandtheit her man sollte Antworten
ja nein
vielleicht sollte man den Duden
einführen ah okay ich habe let letzten
Sprung fehlt noch letzter
Sprung wird Spark den letzten Sprung
schaffen auf jeden Fall
und okay cool Checkpoint ist
offen oder das war Challenge ja nur noch
16 Falltür mit versteckten Gang so wie
es aussieht jetzt eentlich kurz hier
steht build on February 2012 hier steht
alles möglich noch drauf K mit Diamanten
gefunden hat Tür geöffnet
Spa B Challenge 15 hier ist Challenge 16
wollte ich noch mal
sagen ach ja hast du aufgenommen oder
wie viel Uhr haben ich bin gerade dabei
am aufnehmen wir sind gerade bei Minute
10 gut das woll ich nur wissen so chall
16 müs dann h hinten sein oder kan auch
wieder aus dem gamee rausmachen so ja
schmeiß mich auch mit gleich raus lol
sofort mir Skelett
hinterher ja ich schmeiß dich mal kurz
raus so was ist jetzt hier los da
161 aber das ist schon die letzte in der
bzone wir sind schon fast durch ja wir
hab ma aber irendwi auch Spaß ich weiß
jetzt warum theoretisch warum macht das
nur Spaß unglaublich lol wir haben
direkt ein Checkpoint gut 16 162 woll
uns
verarschen okay hier ist ein Schalter
ich weiß nicht was der gebracht hat ach
der das zweite Wasser geöffnet gut
Wasserlevel auch mal interessant
ich habe h schon die Schalter geöffnet
ne du musst quasi nur ein dritten jetzt
gehen und dann da unten rein jumpen und
den dritten Checkpoint Alter ist einfach
gerade ja ist es
auch unten so das der Tunnel zum
zurückgehen go up steh da jump
down ach jetzt muss ich wieder zurück
weil ich da nicht ach das ist blöd man
muss echt immer auf der Wasserhöhe
bleiben ah ja okay zum hangeln so wie so
wie ein better together kennst du eine
Stelle in den Wasser hangeln ja ja weiß
ich noch ach was wir alles schon für
Erfahrung haben ja okay du darfst beim
letzten nicht reinspringen du musst
einfach nur dich reinfallen
lassen schwimm du mal
vor einfach reinfallen lassen jo habe
ich und ich bin trotzdem irgendwie durch
na ja
okay gut irgendwie geh geht mir das
gerade relativ
schnell geht dir schnell
also dafür dass die letzte challenge in
so B ist ist es geht das relativ
schnell okay ich dachte wir werden schon
fertig
ja okay hier wird jetzt schwierig hier
muss man genau ab der höchsten Stelle
einfach mal
runterpringen ah
nein ich sage nicht das
effwort Nein schon wieder
runtergefallen ach mensch verdammt ist
ja ganz wie so eine Ecke wurde ums
Wasser gemusst ja eine ganz böse Ecke
zwei Blöcke von Wasser die diagonal
stehen da muss du durch
na
lecker oh nein
schade so ein
leertastenspiel
ja das Spiel der leeren Taste
ja Nein schon wieder durchgesprungen ach
Mist kleinste Fehler werden h echt
bestraft ja ist so beim Wasser ist echt
fies
ich bin aber gerade auf dem Weg das zu
schaffen ja ich auch und ich hab's
geschafft Checkpoint ist offen ich bin
gerade selber dabei das zu schaffen ja
ja ja ja warte sieh ja nachher in der
Aufnahme wenn du dir überhaupt anguckst
a so nee die D3 Aufnahmen guck ich mir
Regel nicht noch mal an bei ich auch
weil wozu dann eigentlich ist jetzt die
Frage hab's übrigens auch gerade
geschafft so so
so echt diesmal nur ein Wasserspiel und
das geht gerade extrem hoch dieses
Wasserspiel
ja muss einfach bei der passenden Stelle
rausspringen muss ich halt durch den
Wasserfall noch ein bisschen nach
untenen directly hinter dir oh
ja schubst mich nicht so ne ne
rterfallen los nicht fallen bin gerade
runtergefallen war nicht gut ich auch
man sag du mal obwohl es eigentlichit
gar nicht weh tut
ja einfach
nur Kiste öffnen auf einmalum geht das
nicht Glas davor ich habe Connect Text
dann siehst Du gar nichts wollst du
Kiste öffnen au
au um jetzt aufs Thema zurückzukommen
ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht wie
lange müssen wir hier eigentlich noch
durch also wie viele chall wie viele
stages sind das quasi in dieser
Challenge wir sind ja gerade bei 165
kann ich nicht sagen wie viele das sind
166 167 ich glaube weiter als 167 geht's
gar nicht
verdammt dann geh t3c erstmal in eine
kleine Pause und es geht mit the tourist
weiter
jo Ja aber titrac war gar nicht so
schlecht also letzten Folgen hat richtig
Spaß gemacht ja aber ich glaube wenn wir
eine Pause machen ist auchm ganz cool
die Leute was neues zu gucken und ihr
könnt euch auf t3c Comeback bald freuen
stimmt da F nämlich noch ein paar
challenges so die Hälfte haben wir
glaube ich dann rum und das tolle ist
bei dieser Map da kann ich einfach
wirklich die wechseln auf dem Server bei
t3c ist ist nicht wichtig welche
Materialien wir jetzt im Inventar haben
oder so ja deswegen kann ich das da ganz
einfach schnell wechseln
verdammt so echt böse hier gerade im
Moment die Challenge ja ich fall echt
die ganze Zeit darunter wo du auch bist
da bei der Kiste ne übrigens ist der
Part gerade vorbei ich würde sagen
nächster Part ist bei Spark und Tschüss
und tschüss